last week i told you that ukrainian
president vladimir zelensky
survived an assassination attempt there
was this
unit of chechen special forces the
khadiravites and they had been um they
established a plot
to assassinate the ukrainian president
zielenski
and um we now have learned that there
have actually been three such plots
which the ukrainian president has
survived this is being reported by the
new zealand herald and many others
russia ukraine war and again it's really
russian invasion of ukraine president
vladimir zelinsky survives three
assassination attempts in the last week
the ukrainian president has reportedly
survived three assassination attempts in
the past week alone the times in the uk
reports that mercenaries from the
kremlin backed wagner group and chechen
special forces both attempted to kill
the president in the last week according
to reports the assassination attempts
failed because of subversive anti-war
members within russia's federal security
service the fsb which is the successor
to the kgb some elements of the fsb
didn't want this to succeed they didn't
want zolensky assassinated and they
alerted ukrainian officials fascinating
the ukraine secretary of national
security and defense has confirmed three
foiled assassination attempts
he told local media he received
information from double agents who do
not want to take part in this bloody war
according to reports news of one of the
assassination plans sparked the 36-hour
curfew keiv was under last week so
soldiers could sweep the streets for
russian saboteurs civilians were warned
they could be liquidated if they were
spotted outside during curfew as they
would be assumed to be the enemy
sources say the wagner group mercenaries
have been in ukraine since january and
are tracking zolensky and colleagues via
cell phones and then on march one this
is what i told you last week a chechens
uh hit squad also tried to kill zolensky
but failed as the fsb
also reported their movements you know
there's there's a couple of interesting
things to talk about here
um
in the last 10 days
putin
says i have no ill intentions this is a
military operation and yet in the last
10 days
zolensky has survived three
assassination attempts
russia has bombed at least one
kindergarten
at least one orphanage as well as at
least one if not two nuclear power
plants slash sites housing nuclear
reactors okay
so
the the framing
that we have heard from the apologists
for what putin is doing is a very
limited
military operation those can go
in the toilet the same place trump puts
his documents right
but in all seriousness it's
impossible to even imagine what zolensky
and his family are going through right
now and the very interesting thing you
know later we're going to talk about
lindsey graham talking about
assassinating vladimir putin
but yet we've had actual assassination
attempts against zolensky
i believe that if putin were
assassinated
that
would cause a collapse to this entire
this entire invasion
but not the other way and what i mean by
that is as follows
ukrainians actually understand what's
going on they understand that putin has
invaded they understand what they're
fighting for and while zelensky is the
leader
the movement to defend ukraine and
resist russian invasion would continue
even if zolensky were killed if zolensky
were killed
they're still going to do everything
they're doing to repel russia maybe even
bolstered okay there
you that's what would happen if zolensky
were killed on the other hand
many russian troops and even some
russian generals don't seem to think
this is a particularly good idea the
invasion of ukraine
they don't even know what they're
fighting for we have incredible video
from a captured pow russian troop who
was like i don't know we we were told
all this stuff we got here it's not even
really true it's crazy
if putin did die the invasion would
almost immediately end whereas killing
zelensky won't actually uh have that
effect let me know your thoughts
um
find it find me on twitter at deepakman
we'll take a quick break